hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe
euch heute mittag im video gesagt dass
heute noch ein zweites video kommt
deswegen spielen wir heute den docks
simulator wir nehmen als username
einfach das ist ein typischer hunde name
brigitte 69 genauso würde ich definitiv
mein hund tauchen
was ist trocken gehe ich nehme mal
schauten damit das ist entschied und
jetzt haben wir das spiel zerstört wir
klicken einfach mal auf play maximal
hallo ich irgendwie achter in das game
gaullisten wir spielen unser ziel ist es
überall drauf zu pilzen let's get right
into it also wir werden direkt das geld
von mein gott ist die grafik paris dr
keys to move pressed to be ok on as many
things you can you can get down water
von yahoo.de oder get you ein europa der
service game
der board to quickly auf hochtouren ich
glaube ich komme gar nichts merken okay
ich kann mit wenig hochbrücke kann ich
springe nicht an aber er berät die wand
ihr fragt euch wo der zweite hund in
it's also und wenn wir shift gedrückt
halten dann rennen wir schneller und
wenn wir hier bei wasser sind kann nicht
so machen konnte so was
das geht aus den ameisenhaufen mit dem
kopf ich versuche mal zucchini dem nice
argument nein
wie sieht denn meint überaus online denn
los die gegend laufen und laufach kann
schneller laufen kann schneller laufen
schnell ihn ja noch mal an pinkeln laut
hohl hier schnell die laterne an pinkl
aus und den anderen hund los los los los
lauf lauf lauf lauf lauf ihren pinkeln
so schnell schnell und schnell trink
trink und nein
oh mein gott der hund ist weiß und ich
mag mittlerweile dass diese teile hier
ist wir uns einfach wasser holen können
uns hier oder
ja es funktioniert was passiert wenn ich
jetzt hier die piste trinke kann ich
nicht hier trieb seine eigene plätze
schnell und der pc-spiele schwer wie
besonders war okay ich erhoffe mir jetzt
erstmal vorsprung und jetzt pinkl sich
hier nämlich alles an hier ist man die
laterne mit ihm noch da ist er ja schon
wieder an kommt hier noch das schild
eben wie kann ich noch schnell was
trinken schnell weg weiter hier die bank
anpinkeln ihr noch neuen anlauf und lauf
und eine das ist doch nicht war als ob
dieser scheiß besitzer von mir so unfair
da schon wieder
lauf doch okay wir sind wieder
vollkommen aufgefüllt mit trinken das
heißt wir pinkeln hier mal eben schnell
was an so schnell weiter weiter weiter
geknüpft wieso hier eben noch mal was
anpinkeln dann pinkeln wir hier noch mal
eben den hund an es ist wirklich einfach
noch eine abfolge entweder man drückt
shift und nach links laufen oder man so
zäh und schneller laufen und keine
ahnung war hier noch eben schnell die
latte
wir sind wir tot ich verstehe das nicht
wieso sind wir denn gerade gestorben ich
hab einfach alles richtig gemacht ich
trinke ich hier nochmal ein bisschen
eben wasser so oder hinten kommt wieder
mal ein komischer typ den ich hier
nochmal ein bisschen wasser dann pinkl
ich hier eben diesen pfeiler an pinkl
ich hier eben die bank an dir noch eben
den pfeiler anpinkeln hier den links
anpinkeln hier wieder schön das trinken
holen da hinten wieder der duh der
anleihen an ein freunde die zeit geht
runter zeit wir haben ja noch ne
zeitalter geht und um das was während
der zeit ist das ist das spiel vorbei
wenn die zeit jetzt vorbei ist oder
nicht
das spiel ist hat sich auf gehangen es
hat sich tatsächlich gerade aufgabe
bestimmter entwickler dieses spiel ist
ja super toll es macht so viel spaß ist
hat sich aufgaben aber hey ist ja egal
es ist ja nur ein dock simulator hier
geht gerade nicht mein kompletter
browser hat sich irgendwie aufgehangen
wir sind seite reagiert nicht gekommen
wir warten einfach mal noch
okay hier steht immer noch seite
reagiert nicht ich weiß nicht was ich
machen soll wenn ich frauen beendet
erinnert sich auch automatisch die
aufnahme weiß dass so mit neuen
programmen und blau und blog ich würde
sagen dass ihr das zweite video für
heute war lasse ich das jetzt einfach
mal so kurz tut mir leid denn alle die
immer meckern
ich bin nach oder teils auch schon
wieder bei 15 minuten ich kann euch
natürlich in der overtime hochladen aber
ich finde es dann selber nicht so cool
das video ehrlich gesagt ich bin eine
person die lieber ein video am tag
möchte wo ich weiß da ist viel arbeit
drin und das geht einem von mir aus nur
fünf minuten anstatt dass ich vier
videos am tag bekommen die alle 20
minuten lang sind wo einer die ganzheit
und dann redet er mal nicht und blauen
block ich setz immer qualität über
quantität
warum erzähle ich euch das jetzt
eigentlich gerade das auf jeden fall das
ende hier vom video wenn es euch
gefallen habe ich mich meine bewertungen
freuen
ja